- [Voiceover] We're now entering into 1944
where the Americans and
the Allies are able to go
even more on the offensive
versus the Japanese
and get closer and closer to Japan,
get in bombing range of Japan
and deprive the Japanese of,
I guess you could say,
their forward bases.
And so right as we enter into 1944,
and once again I'm giving you an overview
I'm not giving every
single battle that occurs,
the Unites States is
able to take Kwajalein.
Which, once again, the strategic
value of a lot of these,
these islands are tiny
they're barely large enough
to have primitive bases
plus, kind of an air field,
but they're incredibly valuable because
the bombers can land,
refuel, get resupplied
and then take off from there
and then be on the
offensive even further in.
I guess you could say
in Japanese territory.
And with the taking on Kwajalein,
just as a bit of a reminder,
the Americans, amongst other things,
now had control of the Soloman Islands.
They now have control of the
Marshall and Gilbert Islands.
And as we'll see, the real theme of 1944
as we get into the middle
of and the end of the year
is to get as close as possible
to the Japanese mainland.
Because the Americans now had a B-29,
or they had the B-29 bomber
that had a 1500 mile radius.
1500 mile, I guess I
could say 1500 mile range.
Which means if they're
able to get points of
where their bombers
could land and take off,
and once again these bombsers
are way too large and heavy
to land on a carrier,
but if they can find islands
where they can do that from
within a 1500 mile range of Japan
then the United States
could have bombing attacks
directly on Japan and
hopefully get closer to
an end to the war.
So that was really the theme,
get as close as possible to Japan
and then there was a secondary theme
of take back The Philippines.
One, it was a matter of pride,
it was a former US possession
ever since the Spanish-American War.
But then on top of that,
The Philippines are incredibly
strategic for shipping lanes
from Indonesia, remember
those raw materials,
those resources, that
oil that Japan wanted
from Indonesia.
If you control The Philippines
you're gonna control the
shipping lanes between
Indonesia and Japan.
So you could deprive Japan
of those natural resources.
So The United States' kind of
main focal areas in 1944,
get as close as possible to
Japan, get within bombing range,
and take The Philippines.
And this is exactly what they did.
As we go into the summer of 1944,
and one, there were some, as
early as the summer of 1944,
some bombing raids that
took off in China to Japan
with the new B-29s.
So you do have some of these
that happened as early,
some of these bombing
raids happened as early
as summer of 1944.
But in terms of actual
islands, or territory
The United States takes or takes back
in the summer, in June of 1944,
you have The Battle of the Philippine Sea.
So Battle of Philippine
Sea occurs right around,
right around here.
It's a victory for The US.
And it ends up really, really
hurting Japanese ability
to field carriers,
have air warfare from carriers
because so much of their
carrier capability
was damaged in The
Battle of Philippine Sea.
So, The Battle of
Philippine
Battle of the Philippine Sea
this occurs in June
1944.
And along with that, in the summer,
the Allies are able to
take several islands
in The Mariana Islands.
Once again, this is
gonna be super important
because from The Marianas,
they're able to launch
B-29 bombing attacks on
the mainland in Japan.
And so over that summer the Allies,
the Americans in particular,
are able to take Saipan,
they are able to take Guam,
they are able to take Tinian,
which is this little
island right over here.
Some of these islands
are quite hard to find.
They're super small, in fact,
even these little dots
exaggerate their size,
if you were to actually go onto
Google Maps or Google Earth
you'll see how small these are.
And I encourage you to look at them
it's really fascinating to see how small
some of these islands are.
They're really atolls, a lot of these are
more atolls then islands.
Not all of them are atolls.
But you see, they barely have enough space
for a landing strip for
planes, especially the B-29s.
And then as we go further into the summer
and we start entering
kind of later in the year,
the Americans are able to take,
at the time what was called
Peleliu, now it's Palu.
So Peleliu, they're able to take Morotai,
and then perhaps most importantly in 1944,
this might be the biggest
deal out of all of these
pacific battles that
occur and all of these
naval battles that occur,
is The Battle of Leyte an
The Battle of Leyte Gulf.
Because The Battle of Leyte was important
because in the process of taking Leyte
The United States essentially
is able to knock out
the Japanese's ability to further defend,
I mean they will continue,
but realistically defend
the rest of The Philippines.
So once Leyte is taken by the Allies
the odds of the Japanese
being able to hold
the rest of The Philippines
becomes very low.
And maybe even more important,
The Battle of Leyte Gulf, which
occurs right around there,
it's an incredibly decisive
battle for the American Navy.
The Japanese go all in, and
that bet is not a good one.
The Japanese Navy is pretty much destroyed
in The Battle of Leyte Gulf.
And so 1944, once again,
very good year for the Allies.
Very bad year for the Japanese.
Now the Allies are in control of
they're in control of air strips,
from which they can take B-29 raids
to the mainland of Japan.
So air strips,
they can now, they're now within range
to do bombing attacks on
the mainland of Japan,
and they now are very likely
to control The Philippines
and control the shipping
lanes from Indonesia to Japan
and they've all but
destroyed the Japanese Navy.
So, once again, things are not
looking very good for Japan.
And as we go into 1945,
we'll see the Allies
get closer and closer and get more intense
bombing raids on Japan.
And every time they get closer,
the battles to take these islands,
Iwo Jima, Okinawa,
incredibly incredibly bloody
and The United States says,
'Well what do we have to do to get
the Japanese to surrender?'
And we'll see what, at
least in the mind of Truman,
needs to happen.